ja und wir wollen nach köln schauen zwei
männer rasten gestern abend dort aus am
heumarkt mitten in der kölner innenstadt
ja und mitten auch in dieser eisdiele
laut der polizei sind die renditen der
lehrer mit voller absicht in die
eisdiele gegangen um den einstigen
betreiber anzugreifen und der musste
sich dann mit einer holzstange
verteidigen
doch das ist nicht irgendeine ziele die
wir hier sehen sondern eben die ice
cream united und die gehört lukas
podolski
und er ist mir jetzt live zugeschaltet
hallo guten tag herr podolski ja ist ja
eigentlich ein trauriger anlass warum
wir sie jetzt hier zu gast haben was
sagen sie zu hilfe was ist da genau
passiert ja ich weiß eigentlich auch nur
so viel was unsere mitarbeiter gesagt
hat da gab es eine auseinandersetzung
vor dem laden mit drei passanten und
wurde stühle und tische und stühle
umgeworfen wurden auf passanten und auf
unsere mitarbeiter und ja zum glück ist
niemand verletzt aber das ist nicht der
erste vorfall in der ecke wo unser eis
gelegt und da ist auch schon ein
bisschen traurig dass die vor allem die
stadt köln
da bis heute noch nichts unternommen hat
wissen sie dann warum gerade ihre it
gezielt attackiert wurde
nein unser wurde jetzt nicht gezielt
attackiert sondern es die
auseinandersetzung war jetzt vor und
eisdiele wo unser mitarbeiter dann vor
die tür heraus gegangen ist war
natürlich unsere stühle und tische darum
geworfen worden und wollte schlichten
und er wurde dann natürlich attackiert
und ja so viel weiß ich zu dem vorfall
und ja ich weiß dass die zwei oder drei
handel personen dann auch festgenommen
wurden wieder randaliert haben und ja
damit ist hoffentlich das thema erledigt
und die situation beruhigt was fordern
was fordern sie dann von der stadt köln
sie haben ja gerade schon zurecht auch
kritik ja ausgesprochen was fordern sie
konkret was muss sich ändern
ja in köln gibt viele schöne ecken ist
eine tolle stadt
aber natürlich gibt es da auch negative
dinge und das ist es nicht das erste mal
dass vor unserem laden und in der decke
in der ecke am heumarkt leute drogen
konsumieren alkohol zu sich nehmen
randalieren und das ist halt nicht dass
köln was man sehen möchte nicht nur für
die eisdiele oder für die leute sondern
für das gesamtbild der stadt und wie ich
eben gesagt habe das ist nicht das erste
mal passiert sondern dass öfters man
bekommt dann dort immer von der stadt
gesagt ja wir kümmern uns darum ja aber
da passiert leider nichts dann rücken da
immer leute auch vom ordnungsamt wenn
man wenn man seine tische und stühle x 5
cm bisschen weiter an die straße rückt
dann ist immer großalarm aber sonst wird
er leider nicht viel gemacht weil sie
dann vielleicht sogar polizeischutz vor
ihrer einzelne nein so weit ist es nicht
mehr geht hauptsächlich um die ecke weil
es eine schöne ecke ist und da muss
einfach mal in zukunft durchgegriffen
werden darum geht es mir
und ja das einzige thema was dann in
zukunft erledigt werden muss das ist
aber nicht meine aufgabe sondern ich
kann nur appellieren dass eine schöne
ecke unsere stadt muss sauber bleiben
und sich von solchen leuten die sich die
die stadt beschmutzen weg halten und ich
kann die leute nicht festnehmen oder
denen die bestrafung sondern das muss
die polizei oder die stadt köln das
unternehmen dankeschön lukas podolski ja
für diese klaren worte danke schön und
es dann tschüss